bonjour et bienvenue pour ce deuxième
cours de paléontologie des vertébrés
alors la dernière fois nous avons vu
l'origine des vertébrés les aguias tu et
les poissons cartilagineux et
aujourd'hui nous attaquons les poissons
osseux donc les aux states thiès qui
comprennent les actes inoke terry gien
et lessard coop terry gien et qu'ils
vont comprendre donc l'origine des
tétrapodes donc aujourd'hui on va faire
ce qu'on appelle la sortie des eaux avec
des guillemets c'est à dire l'évolution
depuis les poissons jusqu'au tétrapodes
alors pour commencer déjà les aux states
pièces donc pour rappel il y a quatre
grands groupes de vertébrés
il y a les aguias tu donc les poissons
sans mâchoires qu'on oppose aux poissons
avec mâchoire et dans ces poissons avec
mâchoire il ya trois groupes
donc ça fait quatre ans tout donc ces
trois groupes
ce sont d'une part les poissons
cartilagineux et d'autre part les
poissons qu'on va dire au ceux qui
comprennent les activités rien et les
sarko pteris ya donc aujourd'hui on va
s'intéresser à ces poissons osseux donc
les poissons osseux qu'il soit actineo
terry gien ou sarko pts est rien ils
vont avoir déjà ils vont avoir en commun
le fait d'avoir un squelette aussi fier
ce qui n'était jusqu'à présent pas le
cas donc on appelle les chondrites ya
des poissons cartilagineux mais les
aguias tu ne sont pas plus aussi fier
que ça les seuls poissons qui était plus
ou moins aussi fier avant ça c'était les
poissons qui avait un squelette une
espèce de d'armure externe un casque
aussi fier sur la tête donc c'était les
seules traces d'eau si fication qu'on
avait mais ces poissons là sinon leur
squelette interne n'était pas aussi fier
donc c'était d'ailleurs ce casque c'est
plus ou moins de la peau aussi fier
c'est pas vraiment de l'os en fait c'est
pas du vrai os comme les vertèbres par
exemple sont dus entre guillemets vrai
os quoi donc bref donc pour simplifier
les choses on va dire que avant ça
c'était le squelette était cartilagineux
sauf si vous aviez un casque osseux et
après ça donc
après les l'origine d opter aux states
ps
vous avez des poissons qui sont
réellement qui ont réellement le corps
totalement ossifié mais pas de
l'extérieur mais de l'intérieur
voilà et donc et parmi ces eaux
il y en a il y en a une série qui est
plus intéressante et c'est la série d'os
opercules air donc qui forment loupé
recule donc ici c'est simplifier et
montrer sous la forme d'un seul os mais
évidemment il n'y a pas qu'un seul os il
y en a plein et des variations dans la
taille de ses eaux vont vous allez le
voir va être importante
la nageoire donc vous rappeler que les
requins par exemple ont une nageoire tri
basale avec 3oh à la base qui
soutiennent qu'ils attachent la nageoire
à l'épaule chez les aux states pièce
primitivement vous avez une nageoire dit
poli basale avec plein plein de petits
os donc c'est ce qui vous est
représentée en haut à droite ici donc il
ya plein de petits os qui forment une
nageoire poli basale encore une fois ça
va être très important pour la
classification de suivre l'évolution de
ce caractère et les gâteaux ce tome on
ce qu'on appelle une vessie natatoire
vessie natatoire qui est donc une sorte
d'organe un père un organe au milieu du
au milieu du corps et 7 vessie natatoire
elle elle sert à la flottaison et nous
allons voir que cette vessie natatoire
elle va devenir les poumons chez les
sarko terry gien et enfin ils n'ont pas
des pin
contrairement aux as coteaux dyens etc
aux states tiens ils n'ont pas des pin
contrairement des pin sur les nageoires
ni dorsale ni où que ce soit d'ailleurs
sur aucune nageoires
donc contrairement au congrès tient et
contrairement aux attentes au dia donc
ça c'est plutôt un caractère primitif
mais ça les distingue des autres
poissons à mâchoires que sont les
combrit tient et les akans taudière
encore que il y à certains the states ya
qui peuvent avoir des épines et
notamment le
l'un des plus anciens sarcopte originale
qui s'appelle gouyou qui nous vient de
chine avec un nom comme ça en même temps
ça a un nom qui est un peu de qui est un
peu bizarre a prononcé pour nous mais
bon c'est un nom chinois tout à fait
honorable non gouyou c'est le plus
ancien sarko parisien et il a des épines
sur les nageoires au moins une épine sur
la nageoire dorsale donc encore une fois
ça remet en perspective la position des
acanthes odien dans la phylogénie ddd
nyatto ce tome ils sont partout enfin
ils peuvent être possiblement partout et
potentiellement ils étaient partout
c'est à dire potentiellement c'était
juste un autant ils sont anatomiquement
cohérent autant phylogénétiquement
c'était probablement c'était
probablement pas un groupe cohérent du
tout donc on va commencer par les actes
inoke terry gien qui sont souvent
qualifiés de poissons à nageoires
rayonnait donc c'est les poissons
classique on va dire c'est les poissons
que vous avez l'habitude d'acheter au
supermarché par exemple c'est le poisson
qu'on a l'habitude de consommer comme
produit de la pêche
donc ces actes inoke terry gien on les
appelle poisson à nageoires rayonner
parce que ils ont finalement ses rayons
à l'intérieur de la nageoire qui sont
bien visibles alors on appelle ça des
lépi d'autriche et ses rayons alors
c'est pas qu'ils étaient absents chez
les chondrites yahoo chez les ags note
mais c'est qu'on les voit beaucoup moins
bien là la nageoire est généralement
transparente
chez les activités rien donc on voit
très bien les rayons à travers cette
nageoires généralement donc ils n'ont
pas des pin mais on va avoir tout à
l'heure qu'il ya au moins un contre
exemple mais on va aller surtout les
reconnaître plus que par la nageoire
dans le registre fossile on va surtout
les reconnaître par leurs écailles et
donc laisser écailles
elles sont ce qu'on appelle gano id chez
tous les actes ignobles terry gien donc
c'est des écailles qui sont de forme
losange hic parfois même en forme de
larme bon la forme la plus typique vous
la voyez elle est là mais là vous avez
aussi une forme de en forme de larme
comme ça qui est très très très très
beau et c'est très très brillant parce
qu'il ya une très très épaisse couche
d'émail donc encore une fois vous
une écaille qui comporte de l'émail
comme chez les chondrites tient la
différence avec les chondrites tiens
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de dentine cette
fois donc vous vous rappelez la dernière
fois on avait la speed in c'était de la
dentine et de l'os on avait l'équipe là
qu ils s'étaient de l'émail de la
dentine mais pas d'os et maintenant on a
les canaux id c'est de l'émail pas de
dentine et de l'os donc les canaux id si
vous faites une section dedans vous
pouvez la reconnaître au fait qu'elle ne
contient pas de dentine par contre elles
contiennent les mailles et de l'os donc
si vous trouvez une écaille isolé vous
pouvez quand même l'attribuer à un acte
i know parisien en fonction de ce
qu'elle contient donc c'est plutôt
intéressant là que comme vous voyez à la
pointe vers le haut primitivement mais
on va voir que ça va changer au cours de
l'évolution des activités rien et est
d'ailleurs pour parler de l'évolution
des activités rien ici on va vraiment
diviser les activités rien en trois
groupes
morphologiquement plutôt cohérent mais
par contre phylogénétiquement
complètement osef
donc on va vraiment faire les actes
inoke terry gien primitif qu'on appelle
les paléo nici forme
on va faire les palais les actes
ignobles terry gien moyens primitifs et
on va faire les actes ignobles terry
gien traits dérivés
donc les téléostéens donc on va vraiment
faire juste l'évolution des actes
ignobles terry gien en trois étapes
parce que des actes in hope terry gien
c'est la moitié de la diversité de tous
les vertébrés sur terre donc il ya plus
de quarante mille espèces donc je peux
pas aller dans le détail voilà c'est
juste pas possible donc rien
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quarante mille
espèces vous n'imaginez même pas combien
il ya de milliers d'espèces dans le
registre fossile faut simplifier
autrement on n'y comprend plus rien et
déjà là vous allez voir ce sera
suffisamment compliqué donc les actes
ignobles terry gien les plus bas se sont
ce qu'on appelle les paléo nici forme on
les appelait même autrefois l'ailé
condroz ce t1
je ne sais pas si c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui mais bon bref aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt paléo nici forme et c'est
pas léonie si forme
on les reconnaît pas ce qu'ils ont
vraiment des gros c k et gagnent aux ide
bien robuste
bien avec de l'émail bien brillantes
donc ça c'est plutôt primitif ils ont
une queue qui est épices erc donc qui
pointe vers le haut ça aussi c'est
plutôt primitif et ça va changer comme
je les dis et surtout ils ont un
opercule ils ont à nos paires kull
pardon comme les autres aux hôtes et aux
states tient par contre 7 aux percus il
est divisé en plusieurs zones et c'est
au seo vous voyez qui a loupé recul lui
même l'os opercules air lui même qui est
au milieu et il est relativement petit
et ils se partagent en fait la part du
lion avec d'autres zoos le pré opercules
r le sumo percu l'air et sept rangées de
petit haussement qu'on appelle les eaux
brand branche chiot stévia et ça enfin
les rayons branche stévia est donc ce
qu'on va voir en fait au cours de
l'évolution des activités rien c'est
loupé reculèrent prendre la place
dominante sur la série sur les autres os
de la série opercules air dont klaus
opercules herbe à devenir l'os dominant
mais c'est pas encore le cas chez les
paléo nici forme chez les paléo d'ici
forme l'os opercules r est un os parmi
tant d'autres on va dire et les premiers
actes in hope terry gien nous viennent
du dévonien un peu le dévonien c'est
souvent décrit comme l'âge des poissons
parce qu'il y avait tellement de une
énorme diversité d'année est une énorme
diversité de bakhtine hop terry gien une
énorme alors pas une énorme forcément
diversité de condrieu tient mais par
contre c'est aussi là que les chondrites
tient apparaissent et c'est aussi et il
y avait une grosse diversité de sarko
parisien lessard coopté rien était
plutôt diversifiée au dévonien et les
acti nos petits haïtiens vont prendre le
pas dans l'est dans les océans
après que les sarko parisiens aient
disparu des océans mais sarko parisiens
vont continuer à se diversifier en tant
que tétrapodes donc tout n'est pas fini
pour eux mais voilà donc voilà pour les
paléo ni s'ils forment donc originaux
dévonien sans trop de surprise mais
aujourd'hui on a encore des poissons
qu'on qualifie de paléo nici forme ou de
condroz ce t1 est c'est le bischwihr ou
polypes terre qui vit dans les eaux
douces d'afrique et notamment d'afrique
du sud
donc ce bi chirila il est plutôt
primitif dans le sens où il a encore des
bonnes grosses des canaux id bien
losange hic et il a des aussi des ce
qu'on appelle les pilules qui sont en
fait des épines accrochés à des
nageoires dorsales
donc ça c'est un trait extrêmement
primitif ça rappelle pas mal les
attentes bien ça ça ça jette encore un
peu plus le doute sur la position des ac
antonia mais comme je voulais dit si ça
se trouve les à canto dia était
absolument partout c'est un groupe qui
est peut-être mort morphologiquement
cohérent mais pas phylogénétiquement
cohérent du tout par contre il faut se
retenir d'appeler le bichir un fossile
vivant voire même de dire qu'il est
primitive comme gelé comme je viens
justement de le dire il a certains
traits primitif comme les écailles gano
ide et l'épi nul
par contre il a des traits qui sont très
dérivés notamment
il a sept que difficile cal donc
difficile que ça veut dire que la queue
et horizontale elle ne pointent pas vers
le haut et ça c'est un caractère dérivés
c'est un caractère plutôt évolué c'est
une adaptation probablement à son mode
de vie en eau douce donc dans des eaux
peu profondes
on retrouve ça chez d'autres poissons
d'eau douce comme par exemple les dinos
ton retrouvait sachez-le et xena quand
du carbonifère qui étaient des
chondrites tient d'eau douce donc c'est
un caractère qui a l'air d'être associés
aux espèces d'eau douce à l'exception
des olo ses fans qui eux vivent en eaux
très profondes
il a aussi le bichir il a inspira khl
ici qui est directement reliée à sa sa
vessie natatoire et qui lui permet de
respirer l'air et non pas dans l'eau a
dit loeb
non pas en utilisant ses branchies mais
il peut respirer directement l'air au
cas où ça marche ça sèche donc le bichir
retenez-vous d'appeler ça un fossile
vivant parce que c'est parce que
finalement il a quand même quelques
traits qui sont très dérivés et puis
évidemment il a continué à évoluer ce
n'est pas parce que le groupe des paléo
nici formes auxquelles ont leurs
attaches
n'existe plus aujourd'hui que c'est pour
autant que le bishr n'a arrêté d'évoluer
voilà donc le groupe suivant le groupe
des moyens primitifs
le groupe des activités rivière moyens
primitifs se sont celui des eaux lost
est un don qui ils apparaissent à partir
du permien alors que les paléo ni s'ils
forment eux il apparaissait à partir du
dévonien et ils sont encore présents
aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui on
rattache au zoo lost et un les les gars
pic
les esturgeons et aussi les poissons
spatule
d'ailleurs il ya pas longtemps ils ont
réussi à faire un croisement entre eux
est urgent et poissons spatule donc le
croisement n'était pas à donner à
l'animal qui était pas fertile mais
c'est quand même assez ouf de se dire
que le sachant qu'on a des fossiles de
poissons spatule qui date au moins du
jura 6 il me semble voir même du trias
bref c'est sachant que la racine
évolutive de ces deux groupes est au
moins aussi vieille que la divergence
entre les placentaire et les enfin que
les placentaire et marsupiaux et les
mots notres m
en gros c'est comme si vous aviez réussi
à faire un croisement entre un
ornithorynque et un chat ou un
ornithorynque et tient pour reprendre
scarlett johansson voilà c'est c'est
comme un croisement entre un
ornithorynque et scarlett johansson
voilà donc c'est assez c'est assez ouf
en fait que qu'on arrive à faire un
croisement entre un esturgeon est un
poisson spatule parce que vraiment ce
sont des animaux qui normalement ont
divergé il ya très longtemps mais ils
appartiennent quand même au grand
regroupe des eaux lost et à à la grande
famille des eaux lost et un ici je l' ai
mis entre guillemets parce que j'y
inclue aussi le gard pic mais
normalement les eaux lost est assez que
les esturgeons et les c'est que les
esturgeons et les poissons spatule le
gard pic il me semble est censé être
exclu mais bref c'est l'ailé puis le
gard pics on les appelle aussi dès
l'épisode t si on veut que les eaux lost
et à swaps soit monofil éthique du moins
mais qu'encore une fois je ne prends que
les groupes cohérent morphologiquement
parce que mes étudiants ne sont pas
censés avoir fait de philo jeudi au
moment où je fais secours
donc voilà les eaux lost et un avec des
guillemets mais quand même ils sont
quand même relativement proches les uns
des autres suffisamment vous voyez pour
faire des bébés
même si ces bébés ne sont pas fertile
donc lécher les hollows t1 trêve de
digression chez les eaux lost et 1
on a une écaille on a des écailles gano
et des grosses des cas et gagnent au
heat bien épaisse une fois de plus comme
chez les paléo ni s'ils forment donc
comment est ce qu'on fait la différence
on a toujours une queue épices arcal
comme chez les paléo ni s'ils forment
donc comment est ce qu'on fait la
différence avec les paléo nici forme et
basse et en faisant c'est en regardant
les les rayons branche lost et vient
donc rappelez-vous chez les paléo nici
forme il y en a tout plein ébat chez les
ch et les actes chez les hollows t1
on a très peu très peu et loupé recule
du coup devient le laus opercules air
devient un peu plus important vous avez
toujours le pré opercules r le sumo
percu l'air mais le los opercules air
lui même devient de plus en plus
importants et les aux branches lost et
gien sont réduits vous avez aussi un
nouveau un nouveau caractère qui
apparaissent et l'apparition de l'os dix
simples et tic qui crée une nouveau type
d'articulation dans la mâchoire qui
permet de projeter la mâchoire un peu
plus vers l'avant donc ça ça apparaît
chez les eaux lost et à mais ça va se
perfectionner celle été le host et un au
point de leur donner une mâchoire qui va
pouvoir se projeter vers l'avant comme
celle et comme chez les requins et les
raies donc les plus anciens viennent du
permis a et on en a toujours aujourd'hui
puisque nous avons toujours des
esturgeons des gares pics et des
poissons spatule et d'ailleurs j'en
profite tant qu'à parler de poissons
spatule si vous aussi vous vous rappelez
le cette découverte en fait de poissons
qui se sont fossilisés à la suite
vraiment directement à la suite de la
chute de la météorite qui a deux qui a
provoqué l'extinction des dinosaures non
aviens
en fait cette ces dépôts dont qui se
sont formés juste quelques heures qu'on
a pu dater de je crois de seulement huit
heures après la chute de la météorite en
fait ils contiennent beaucoup de
poissons fossilisés ces poissons sont
essentiellement des gares piquer des
poissons spatule et enfin le groupe des
téléostéens donc qui est le groupe de
d'actine obtient le plus diversifiée
puisque les les olo ce terrain on les
compte sur les doigts d'une main et puis
les paléo nici forme il n'y a plus que
le bichir qui vit encore aujourd'hui
donc les télés au stella c'est tout le
reste des poissons donc tout le reste de
ses quarante mille espèces d'actine
aubeterre et gien dont je vous parlais
ce sont des téléostéens donc c'est les
poissons quand on dit le mot poisson on
visualise à l'animal c'est un
téléostéens voilà c'est à peu près ça
l'idée
donc le ton le maquereau les toutous les
poissons vous pouvez manger ou presque
sur l'étal du du poissonnier c'est c'est
ça les poissons chats font aussi partie
les carpes koï enfin bref voilà nouveaux
poissons d'aquarium vos poissons le
voilà nemo nemo les tous les poissons
d'aquarium ou presque sont des sondés
téléostéens au cas où vous vous poseriez
la question est alors comment on
reconnaît les téléostéens si vous vous
demandez si votre poissons d'aquarium
éteintes et les os t1 ou non eh bien il
faut regarder les écarts les cadeaux id
n'est plus chez les téléostéens on a un
nouveau type des cayes qui est
uniquement fait d'une très fine couche
dos lamellaire et qu'on appelle les
cales les cailles stéroïdes ou cyclo ide
en fonction de si elle forme un cercle
complet ou juste un demi cercle
et du point de vue historique 7 écailles
cyclo id ou kinoïde se différencie de
les cayes gano icare n'a plus des
mailles et elle n'a plus qu'une seule
couche dos lamellaire donc sénécail qui
est très très fine quasiment
transparente qui est vraiment
caractéristique des téléostéens on a
aussi loupé recul homme qui n'a plus de
rayons branche était bien du tout donc
il ya plus qu'un seul gros sauts percu
l'air c'est ce que vous pouvez voir là
sur ce poisson par exemple sur ce
poisson fossiles et la nageoire est
devenu au mot cercle
alors c'est un nouveau type de nageoires
une fois de plus mais qui est très très
particulier en fait c'est un peu comme
une nageoire dix fils errent que dans le
sens où elle est horizontale mais au
lieu d'être juste horizontale comme
celle bichir et d'avoir vous voyez juste
des rayons autour et un bout pointu et
bien elles divergent en fait vers le
haut et vers le bas
elle va diverger est donnée de loeb à
peu près de la même taille
d'où le terme oh mon cercle donc ces
deux clubs sont à peu près de la même
taille et en fait aucun des deux ne
contient la colonne vertébrale la
colonne vertébrale vous voyez elle
s'arrête au niveau d'un gros zozos ce
qui est la fusion de plein de petites
vertèbres et qu'on appelle la spirale
donc c'est au cip ural va être le point
d'attaché de tous les rayons qui vont
former la queue au mot cercle dont les
deux lobes vont être à peu près égaux s
est aussi pur halle est typique des
téléostéens donc c'est pour ça celui là
par exemple si vous regardez ce tomb
pourriat rodgers mystique été nommé
d'après rogers smith à mes collègues
donc si vous regardez ce fossile ce
poisson fossiles ici vous pouvez déjà
déduire qu'il s'agit d'un poisson aussi
fier parce que vous voyez que le
squelette est aussi fier il n'y a pas de
c'est pas un poisson cartilagineux et
vous pouvez dire que c'est un
téléostéens parce qu'il a déjà parce
qu'il n'a pas des canaux id vous pouvez
pas voir des canaux ide et au cas où
vous avez un doute
il a un gros opercules il a un aussi pu
râle sur lequel sont attachées de lob de
queue qui sont à peu près de la même
taille
voilà là que homo cercle aussi pur al
tous les ingrédients sont là pour faire
de ce petit poisson un téléostéens et
des fois on voit même chez les
téléostéens là
la nageoire pelvienne et déplacé vers
l'avant des fois même plus vers l'avant
que la nageoires pectorales donc ça veut
dire qu'en gros il a les jambes presque
plus en avant du corps que les que les
bras donc ça ça arrive assez souvent
aussi chez les téléostéens donc c'est si
vous voyez que les nageurs pelvienne
sont très très en avant généralement
vous êtes entre c'est que vous regardez
un téléostéens
donc ça il n'y a pas trop de doutes sur
l'identification de ces animaux alors
maintenant on va focaliser un peu plus
sur le dévot niant dévonien durant
lequel voit se produire une transition
évolutive importante cette transition
évolutive c'est les poissons qui vont
sortir de l'eau ces poissons les
poissons vont sortir de l'eau durant le
dévot n'y un essai donc l'évolution des
sarko parisien qui est documenté en
afrique du sud donc par ce qu'on appelle
le 8b regroupe donc toujours dans ces
montagnes du cap mais plus coté car ou
déjà que côté capetown du côté du cap
en france on a quelques restes de sarko
parisien on en a pas des masses non plus
mais c'est surtout c'est surtout le
groenland la norme
enfin les pays scandinaves qui vont
donner les bords registre fossile de
poisson sarko pts et régions donc comme
je le disais les sarko petit rien c'est
un groupe important puisque c'est le
groupe qui fait la transition entre la
mer et le continent et c'est là qu'on va
voir la nageoire se transformer petit à
petit en membres antérieurs et
postérieurs donc la transformation
l'apparition de ce qu'on appelle le
membre qui riediens donc sinon ça ça
doit vous rappeler des cauchemars de
quand vous étiez ans en terminale ou en
première voilà si vous avez fait ce psv
était notamment vous avez dû entendre
parler du membre qui riediens et ça a dû
vous vous filer des boutons ces termes
là aussi le stylo pod le gôpô de l'auto
pod
mais bon vous inquiétez pas on va on va
détailler tout ça et on va essayer de
rendre ça le plus intelligible possible
alors quatrième et dernier groupe grand
groupe de poissons donc de vertébrés de
vertébrés non terrestre
dans ce quatrième et ultime grand groupe
de poissons ce sont les sarko térésiens
ou poisson à nageoires charnues alors
pourquoi poisson à nageoires charnue je
vais peut-être vous trouvez une petite
image si je peux voilà pourquoi on
appelle ça les poissons à nageoires
charnue j'avance un peu sur le sur le
power pop mais évidemment je vais
en arrière c'est parce qu'en fait en
plus des rayons si vous regardez ce
coelacanthe en plus des rayons
il ya aussi un lob de chair à la base de
la nageoire et ce lob de chair en fait
c'est ce qui donne le nombre poisson à
nageoires charnues alors pourquoi est ce
qu'il y à un lob de cher chez ces
poissons à nageoires charnues et bien
parce que il y a des eaux à l'intérieur
des nageoires et notamment un long gosse
qui est l'équivalent en voilà deux qui
est l'équivalent de l'humérus ici en
rouge est qui et qui s'appelle le stylo
pod
voilà donc il ya un long gosse ici qui
s'appelle le stylo pod est qui et qui va
donner en fait attache à des muscles et
vous voyez qu'il est suivi par d'autres
zones certains d'entre eux vont soutenir
les rayons mais les autres en fait ils
sont attachés à des muscles et ses
muscles en fait vont donner à la
nageoire cette apparence charnues
d'ailleurs ça me fait ça me fait vous
souligner au passage que ce qui attache
la nageoire à l'épaule
c'est un seul et unique hausse le stylo
pod donc la nageoire est mono basale au
lieu d'être poli basale comme chez les
acti n'opter rien la nageoire et mono
basale donc ça c'est une différence qui
va être fondamentale chez sarko pts est
rien puisque encore aujourd'hui votre
nageoire est mono basale vous n'avez
qu'un seul humérus vous n'avez qu'un
seul fémur donc votre ceinture
scapulaire votre ceinture pelvienne ne
sont attachés à vos membres que par un
seul os
exactement comme les sarko pts et rien
que nous allons voir maintenant
ensuite les écailles donc encore une
fois quatrième groupe de poissons de
poissons quatrième type des cas est
différent cette fois c'est les cailles
cosmo ide qui caractérise les sarko
pirisiens donc qu'est ce qu'elle a de
spécial c'était caicos moïse alors
résumé début de l'épisode précédent
les cayes a speeding enfin les écailles
des des agriates quand il avait des
écailles donc au dévonien
elle était fait d'os
et de dentine les écailles des
chondrites tiens sont comme des dents
elles sont faits d'émail et de dentine
les écailles des acti n'opter rien donc
les cas y gagnent aux ide
elle est faite des mailles et d'os mais
pas de dentine les cailles cosmo id ca
combo des cartes donc l atout elle à
l'émail est là la dentine et elle a los
donc c'est un peu le combo ultime et
curieusement c'est tekaya été
complètement a complètement disparu chez
les tétrapodes mais on la retrouve
encore aujourd'hui chez le coelacanthe
par exemple donc 7 et caicos moïse
elle est typique des sarko parisien du
dévonien donc ça c'est voici à quoi elle
ressemble donc elle n'a pas du tout la
forme losange hic des écailles gano id
elle est légèrement brillante parce
qu'elle a une fine couche d'émail mais
cette couche d'émail et relativement
fine puisqu'il ya aussi de la dentine
est de l'os encore pas rendu là que
aussi est différente chez de shell de
celle des dessins des acti n'opter rien
l édifice erc
donc elle est complètement horizontal et
elle a cette particularité d'avoir trois
de porter trois lobes donc ça se voit
c'est très bien chez le coelacanthe en
fait il ya toujours 3 loeb sur 7 sur 7
que difficile
donc c'est c'est comme la queue
difficiel que des d'autres poissons
qu'on a pu voir avant comme le bichir
par exemple
sauf que contrairement aux bichir ya pas
qu un bout pointu il ya trois l'aude qui
se développent et donc ces trois lobes
vont être particulièrement arrondi chez
le coelacanthe lui donnant cette forme
de trèfle traits caractéristiques du
coelacanthe trèfle à trois feuilles
évidemment pas à quatre feuilles et deux
autres caractère important des sarko
quiérysiens c'est aussi la présence la
présence d'un d'une articulation à
l'intérieur du crâne en fait la boîte
crânienne et le museau sont articulés
l'un par rapport à l'autre
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le joint
intracrânien ou l'articulation
intracrânienne et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve que chez les sarkozy
indien et qu'on va même retrouvé
chez les tétrapodes plus tard jusqu'au
pélico szohr donc même les pays causeur
les ancêtres des dt raps idée des
mammifères même cpedi cause or vont
encore avoir le joint intracrânien qu'on
trouve qui apparaît avec l'ancêtre
commun des sarko pts et rien donc le
museau ici est capable de bouger par
rapport à la boîte crânienne et ça aide
en gros à la déglutition ça aide à
attraper les trois ça a vraiment à voir
avec la nutrition quoi ça permet au
museau de bouger indépendamment de la
boîte crânienne
un peu comme chez les serpents en fait
est un dernier caractère important c'est
un caractère dentaire c'est la présence
de dents labyrinthe aux dons donc c'est
dans l'habit râteau dont elles ont la
particularité d'être strié quand on est
un verbe de l'extérieur et quand on les
coupe en fait quand on fait une coupe
transversale
on se rend compte que c'est ce tri
nations sont dus à des replis de l'émail
qui donne un aspect en labyrinthe à la
dent et ccc repli de l'émail qui donne à
ces dans leur désignation de dents
labyrinthe aux donc et ça aussi c'est un
caractère intéressant parce qu'on va le
retrouver jusque encore une fois chez
les ch et les amphibiens et même chez
certains pays qu aux orres donc c'est
vraiment un caractère qui fait la
connexion entre des animaux qu'on
qualifierait de poissons et des animaux
qu'on qualifie définitivement de
tétrapodes voire même d'ancêtres des
mammifères donc il ya vraiment un
il ya vraiment des caractères qui
apparaissent ici à la souche des sarko
parisien à la souche vraiment de des
poissons qui vont un jour devenir des
tétrapodes il ya des caractères qui
apparaissent là qui font la connexion
d'une connexion profonde entre 7 et
rapide même des tétrapodes qu'on
considérait comme très dérivés et des
trucs qui ressemble fondamentalement à
des poissons donc le plus vieux sarko
parisien ségou your own eros de la fin
du silurien de chine
mais elle est vraiment le grand de
radiation la grande diversification des
sarko parisien c'est le dévonien et
évidemment les sarko pirisiens existe
toujours aujourd'hui
même si vous ne comptez pas les
tétrapodes comme des poissons sarkozien
vous pouvez toujours compter le
coelacanthe et lé dinh est donc le
premier est l'un des plus importants
groupes de poissons sarko parisien ce
sont les activistes ya ce qu'on appelle
plus basiquement laisser là quand donc
ces c'est là quand ils sont très
reconnaissables par leur que comme je
voulais 17 que l es en forme de trèfle
donc vous avez 3 loeb mais c'est loeb
sont très arrondi ce qui donne cette
forme de trèfle à trois feuilles qu'on
retrouve jusqu'au dévonien chez des
poissons comme serenitis dont vous voyez
ici un fossile alors évidemment celui là
la queue n'est pas bien préservé mais on
a beaucoup beaucoup de fossiles de
serenity ce qui préserve la les tissus
mous et notamment en afrique du sud en
afrique du sud on a un très beau
gisement qui s'appelle la lafam waterloo
et 7 farm
voilà la waterloo farm donc la ferme
waterloo et cette ferme waterloo elle a
livré beaucoup de série need is de tous
les âges y compris énormément de
juvéniles d'ailleurs ce qui fait penser
que à cette époque là il devait y avoir
une genre de nursery de deux sites de
pontes de sela quant à cet endroit là
donc serenitis vous voyez les trois
lobes arrondie font de lui un
coelacanthe il ya aussi une absence de
l'os maxillaire
donc ça c'est typique des décès là quand
d'ailleurs les tétrapodes ont un os
maxillaire hasselhoff qui porte ici vovo
molères et de toutes vos dents depuis
votre canine jusqu'à vos mots l'air sont
situés sur votre os mac si l'air mais
laissez là quand eux n'en n'ont pas donc
c'est ce qui fait que le coelacanthe
n'est pas directement ne peut pas être
directement l'ancêtre en plus du fait
qu'on vit à la même époque donc on peut
difficilement être l'ancêtre la nôtre
mais il retient c'est ce qui fait que
les coelacanthe ne sont pas directement
les ancêtres des tétrapodes par contre
il partage effectivement certains traits
avec les tétrapodes et notamment la
présence du stylo pod
donc ça c'est de la nageoire mono basale
ce qui fait quand même du coelacanthe un
pont anatomique entre les entre les
poissons sarko terry gien et les sarko
petit rien tétrapodes
est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant avec les
coelacanthe c'est qu'ils n'ont pas de
poumons
d'ailleurs ils n'ont pas non plus de
vessie natatoire les coelacanthe n'ont
rien du tout mais par contre on sait
d'après des fossiles qu'ils avaient des
pouilles enfin qu'ils avaient une vessie
natatoire mais par contre ils n'avaient
pas non plus il n'avait pas de poumons
donc ils n'ont jamais on a des fossiles
qui nous disent que les coelacanthe
n'ont jamais eu deux poumons
voilà c'est ça l'idée quoi donc le
premier coelacanthe évidemment quand on
fait un cours dans un contexte africain
on ne peut pas se retenir de rappeler
que le premier coelacanthe du genre
l'ati mejia a été repêché en afrique du
sud et son existence a été saigné à
signaler en 1938 par courtney la team
heures
d'où le nom l'ati mejia et c est ce
n'est qu'une des deux espèces de
coelacanthe qui vivent encore
aujourd'hui donc c'est pareil dire que
le coelacanthe est un fossile vivant
c'est faux parce que déjà il ya deux
espèces de celle à quand donc lequel des
deux est un fossile vivant
1 et en plus c'est négliger le fait que
pour être un fossile vivant encore
faut-il avoir un registre fossile
or la ti meriane a pas de registre
fossile on n'a aucun fossile de latimer
ya à l'heure actuelle et quand on
regarde le registre fossile on pourrait
dire ah oui mais laissez là quand ils
n'ont pas beaucoup évolué et mes fesses
parce que les coelacanthe si vous
regardez bien ils ont changé pas mal de
formes et de tailles macro poma était un
coelacanthe géant rebelles atrix vous
pouvez voir finalement à laisser tomber
la queue arrondis pour avoir cette forme
de queue très pointu qui indique que
c'était un nageur rapide
vous avez même des coelacanthe qui ont
aussi laissé tomber la queue en forme de
trèfle pour une queue totalement dix
fils errent qu donc pointu exactement
comme celle est exactement comme chez
les bichir ce qui indique d'ailleurs ça
se voit aussi chez celui là ce qui
indique d'ailleurs que lé premier
coelacanthe étaient plutôt des animaux
d'eau douce alors que les coelacanthe
d'aujourd'hui sont des animaux marins
donc c'est pareil il ya eu un changement
physiologique très très très important
entre les premier coelacanthe et les
coelacanthe moderne
bref voilà c'est l'histoire d
coelacanthe c'est un peu plus que juste
un machin qui est apparu au dévonien qui
a pas changé depuis
donc c'est pareil fossile vivant non un
pas fossiles vivants
faut arrêter avec ces histoires l'autre
groupe de sark de poissons sarko petit
rien qui est très important c'est celui
des dinos tu les dinos
ils sont un peu plus proche des
tétrapodes parce qu'ils vont posséder
des poumons
alors quelle est la différence entre une
vessie natatoire et un poumon
bah c'est très simple en fait les
poumons vous en avez 2 alors que les
vessies natatoires il y en a qu'une et
les poumons évidemment vont servir à
respirer encore que on avait l'exemple
du bichir qui se servait de sa vessie
natatoire pour respirer donc la
différence c'est vraiment le fait que
les poumons soit un organe père alors
que la vessie natatoire est un organe un
père et cette paire de poumons donc chez
les dinos et elle va servir à respirer
les dix nous devons vont pouvoir
respirer de l'air particulièrement quand
leur lama les petites mares temporaires
dans lesquelles ils vivent vont
s'assécher et après quand ces mares
temporaires vont être complètement sèche
les dinos vont faire un genre de
terriers vont s'enfermer dans une sorte
de sac rempli d'eau remplis d'eau et
vont estives et le temps que la pluie
reviennent donc ça c'est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant c'est qu'on retrouve
justement ses terriers à l'état de
fossiles au moins jusqu'aux dévonien et
ils sont particulièrement abondants au
permien en afrique du sud
dans le cas où donc c'est un groupe qui
va être assez important qui va avoir un
très très bon registre fossile du fait
de ses terriers et aussi du fait des
dents qu'ils laissent derrière eux les
dinos ont la particularité d'avoir de
très très grosses dents sur le palais
mais aucune dent sur les maxillaires
d'ailleurs vous pouvez voir ici là vous
voyez le bord de la mâchoire ici est
complètement édenté donc on n'a pas du
tout dedans marginales par contre on à
ces grosses dents palatine et vous voyez
ça c'est un exemple dedans qu'on
retrouve
dans le trias du caroux donc c'est des
très grosses dents enfin très grosse par
rapport à la taille du crâne évidemment
sinon la dent en elle-même elle est pas
plus gros que l'ongle de mon petit doigt
mais ce sont quand même des dents de
bonne taille comparé à la taille du
crâne et qui ont une morphologie
absolument unique
il n'y a pas de y'a pas à tortiller
quand vous trouvez ça vous savez que
vous avez que vous êtes face à un dîner
est maintenant lady ne se sont pas
totalement sont pas encore une fois
directement les ancêtres des tétrapodes
ils ont leur petit spécialisation
notamment la queue est totalement dix
fils errent que tous les dinos modernes
qui sont répartis en trois genres ont
une queue dix fils errent qui n'est pas
trilobé contrairement aux autres sarko
parisien et ça c'est encore une fois une
adaptation à un mode de vie en eau douce
et est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
d'ailleurs chez les dinos tu sais aussi
d'observer la symétrie de la nageoire
donc la nageoire est symétrique dans le
sens où vous avez autant de rayons d'un
côté que de l'autre et les eaux en fait
du milieu là vous voyez les aux axiaux
forme d'un axe justement et ils sont pas
divisés de façon asymétrique c'est
important de le pointer du doigt
maintenant c'est aussi c'était aussi le
cas chez le coelacanthe mais je pense
que c'est important de le pointer du
doigt maintenant parce que ça va changer
ça chez les tétrapodes donc et ça va
changer dans la prochaine au prochain
groupe qu'on va regarder
voici un exemple de terriers enfin deux
structures de terriers de de dinos tu es
donc voiles et voiliers la répartition
des dinos était très intéressante
aujourd'hui parce que vous avez trois
genres donc proto pts et russe en
afrique n'est osséja tonus en australie
et lépide aux sirènes en amérique du sud
proto de thé russe et lépide aux sirènes
on sait le caractère curieux d'avoir des
nageoires très très fine nez au cera
tonus lui par contre conserve des
grosses nageoires bien charnues c'est
vrai que quand on montre proto pts et
russes comme ici et qu'on montre
sceptique nageoires très très fine
on a du mal à croire que c'est un
poisson à nageoires charnue mais né au
cera tonus est là pour montrer que ses
nageoires sont bel et bien
et justement maintenant on va arriver
aux animaux qui sont un peu plus
problématique
un peu plus problématique dans le sens
où si dans votre tête vous avez une case
poisson et une case tétrapodes et
lepisto steger qu'on va voir maintenant
va un peu percé toutes vos cases donc on
va commencer déjà par ce qui pourrait
faire des lepisto steger un animal
plutôt dans la case poisson donc
qu'est-ce qui fait donc les caractères
poissonneux des caractères ikhtiyar de l
pisto steger
c'est déjà la forme générale du corps la
forme générale du corps est plutôt
hydrodynamique
on est face à un animal qui a
définitivement vous voyez une nageoire
caudale
donc on et puis il ya aussi des
nageoires sur les bras et les jambes il
ya toujours des lipides autriche sur ses
nageoires
donc ça c'est plutôt poisson il a
toujours des écailles cosmo ide qui lui
couvrent le corps donc ça c'est toujours
plutôt un caractère de sarko pts et
rigide de poissons sarko parisien par
contre il a aussi des caractères qui le
font ressembler à des intégrateurs et
notamment il assez ils associent pour
lui qu'il a un corps déjà tout plein
donc il n'est pas aussi hydrodynamique
que ça si vous regardez le coelacanthe
par exemple qui lui vit dans les eaux
bien ouverte
son corps est aplati sur les côtés
latéralement donc il a un corps qui est
plutôt ovale mais dans le sens vertical
elle piste au cg lui l' accord qui est
plutôt aplatit et en section il aurait
plutôt l'air ovale mais dans le sens
horizontal et ça c'est parce qu'ils
vivaient dans des eaux peu profondes
voire même pourquoi pas de temps en
temps sur terre un peu comme les un peu
comme nos amis les d'hypnos teint il
devait faire quelques petites incursions
terrestres
il était capable de respirer et ça on le
sait parce que il a ce qu'on appelle
d'écho and donc les kohan ce sont des
narines interne donc lady ne se sont
capable de respirer sans qu anne mais on
sait que les narines internes n'ont
absolument aucun intérêt
si on ne respire pas l'oxygène de l'air
pourquoi parce que quand on était un
poisson
on n'a pas besoin de kohan tout
simplement parce que on utilise nos
narines que pour l'olfaction donc que
pour renifler en fait donc l'eau rentre
dans le lot rentrer dans une première
narines passe à côté du lobe effectifs
et ressorts et les molécules odorantes
ont été captés par les lobbies olfactif
voilà c'est la seule utilité de vos
narines
par contre si vous avez une kohan ça
veut dire que l'eau rentre par ici
rentrer dans la bouche
et puis vous en faites quoi vous en
faites quoi vous en fait vous vouloir
cracher c'est pas un système plus
efficace que ça la seule raison qui
justifierait d'avoir des clones
au lieu de ce système là c'est que une
fois de temps en temps voire même
relativement souvent vous sortez de
l'eau et vous aller respirer l'air qui
va rentrer dans votre marine et se
diriger vers vos poumons
donc la présence de kohan c'est un très
fort indice que l pisto steger avait des
poumons et le fait qu'il soit plus
dérivés que les les poissons que les que
les d'hypnose qui eux mêmes ont des
poumons appuient cette hypothèse
on a aussi l'existence d'un canal
lacrymal chez lepisto steger ce canal
lacrymal permet d'humidifier le le globe
oculaire humidification qui n'a aucun
intérêt si vous êtes si vous vivez dans
l'eau pendant 24 heures de votre vie et
sept jours sur sept
donc ça tu utilises 7 ce canal lacrymal
il sécrète un faux semblants d'eau de
mer qui permet d'humidifier votre globe
oculaire la forme du crâne des lepisto
steger et très très très intéressante
parce que c'est exactement la même forme
du crâne qu'on va voir chez les
amphibiens du permien regardez bien la
forme en v aplati de ce crâne avec les
yeux bien au sommet du crâne
ici donc des yeux qui sont un peu comme
ceux des crocodiles à qui devait se
placer en juste à la surface de l'eau
si vous imaginez la surface de l'eau
juste ici vous pouvez imaginer que
l'animal avait sous ses yeux qui sortait
de l'eau mais qui pouvait conserver
de cette façon tout le reste du corps
immergé donc on est peut-être un
chasseur embusqués qui devait vivre à la
manière des crocodiles et vous avez ici
des petites encoches c'est encore ce
qu'on appelle les encoches aux tic ou ou
bien tout simplement les eaux les oui
quoi donc c'est la naissance aussi de
l'audition sur terre avant ça on ne
pouvait pas les poissons ne pouvait pas
entendre parce qu'ils n'avaient pas dans
kof et 7
et c'est encore elles sont là pour une
raison très simple
enfin elles sont lâchés elle pissos tg
mais pas chez les autres poissons pour
une raison très simple c'est que à
l'arrière de la tête chez les autres
poissons donc si on va voir par exemple
le coelacanthe à l'arrière de la tête
ici vous avez loupé recul opercules qui
est lui même attaché aux épaules et vous
pouvez voir ici que le brass attache
directement à l'épaule qui attachés à
l'operculé qui est attaché au crâne
donc tout est attachés ensemble mais
celle piste host et j'ai les épaules
enfin les opercules et les épaules sont
détachés du reste du crâne donc
l'arrière du crâne est libre ici vous
avez et il y en a un coût donc le coût
qui permet de basculer la tête de bouger
la tête quand on est à l'air libre qui
est a plutôt un problème quand on vit
sous l'eau parce que le coût en fait ils
brisent l'hydrodynamisme les poissons
n'ont pas de coups parce que tout
simplement ils n'ont pas besoin de
bouger la tête ils ont même plutôt
besoin en fait d'avoir une tête bien
rigide et aligné avec le corps pour
l'hydrodynamisme la cie la tête elle
peut bouger dans tous les sens et le
corps aussi
c'est plutôt un problème niveau
hydrodynamisme et là on est sur un
animal qui était plutôt qu'ils avaient
des adaptations au milieu terrestre et
notamment la présence d'un coup et de
fait ça libère l'arrière du crâne pour
qu'un trou qu'ils soient qui est dirigé
vers l'oreille puisse permettre d'avoir
une membrane tympanique et que cette
membrane tympanique ans voilées sont le
signal sonore vers l'oreille interne
donc c'est la naissance de l'audition
c'est la naissance d
si vous comparez justement ce crâne un
crâne d'amphibiens plus tardif un crâne
du permien dont quelles pistes hausse tg
il vivait au dévonien
donc là on est sur un crâne du permien
beaucoup plus tardif plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'années après ça vous voyez
les yeux de cet amphibien sont toujours
situés au sommet du crâne il y a
toujours cette petite encoche ici et la
forme du crâne en général tout plat est
plutôt arrondies à l'avant c'est très
typique d'un amphibien dont quelques
pistes aux steger en fait il a un corps
de poisson avec une tête d'amphibiens
quoi donc je sais il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont allergiques au terme de
chaînons manquants mais là je peux pas
me retenir
là on est sur un intermédiaire en termes
de structure qui est absolument idéal
quoi le corps de poisson la tête de
d'amphibiens c'est voilà vous avez deux
structures sur 1,2 structure
complètement différentes sur un même
animal et après quand on regarde quand
on regarde les membres des listes host
et j'ai ça devient encore plus
intéressant donc l'avant qu'on attaque
les pattes
voici une illustration de ce qui se
passe en fait avec les épaules et les
opercules donc ici vous avez le sténopé
rejeter n'opteront dont j'ai pas parlé
parce que c'est un c'est un animal qu'on
ne trouve que au canada et elle piste au
stage
enfin c'est un animal qu'on trouve dans
l'hémisphère nord uniquement et l piste
au stage et vient aussi de l'hémisphère
nord donc j'ai pas envie non plus de
présenter trop d'animaux qui ne se
trouvent pas dans l'hémisphère sud
donc je préfèrerais parler des lepisto
steger qui lui pour le coup vraiment
face et c'est vraiment l'intermédiaire
parfait quoi plutôt que sténose theron
qui dans l'absolu est très similaire
à un dîner est à quelques détails près
quoi donc
donc voici et puis voici le sténopé
theron qui est donc un sarko parisien
vous voyez ici les épaules loupé recul
et le crâne
donc les épaules en violet loupé recul
en vert foncé le crâne en vert clair ici
vous avez un pan d'eric this donc encore
ça c'est plutôt un sarko parisien qui
commence déjà à devenir un peu comme une
puce soc tg le crâne est aplati le
museau et arrondis mais vous avez
toujours le crâne qui est attachée à
l'opéra culte qui est attachée à la aux
épaules et ici vous avez un camp toaster
gars qui a le crâne complètement séparée
de des épaules et les opercules ici qui
ont disparu ou se sont attachés
finalement au à la à la ceinture
scapulaire est donc l piste au cg il est
définitivement plus de ce côté là de la
force que de ce côté là et pourtant mais
avec avec une forme de crâne qui est
quand même similaire à celle de pande
erik thysse donc il est vraiment entre
port d haïti c'est un cantos tega donc
maintenant les membres les membres donc
comme je les dis ils ont des sondés lépi
d'autriche donc ça c'est plutôt un
caractère de poisson mais quand on
regarde les membres d'el piste d'al
pisto steger
ici on voit en fait une asymétrie du
membre donc vous avez l'humérus enfin
l'équivalent de l'humérus le stylo pod
vous avez vos 2 the gods ici donc ce qui
serait l'équivalent du radius et de l'ul
nation parle de la main ou du tibia et
de la fibula si on parle du de la jambe
et ici vous avez d'autres zoos qui sont
équivalents de l'auto pod donc les
métatarsien où les méta qu'un les
carpien et les métacarpien et où l'état
retient les métatarsien selon vous
regardez le bras ou la jambe et ya même
chez les pistes host et j'ai deux petits
sauts au bout que les que les gens qui
ont décrit cet animal ont interprétés
comme des doigts ou du moins des débuts
doigt des phalanges quoi c'est très
intéressant parce que cette asymétrie en
fait de la nageoire qu'on voit très bien
ici là c'est tiktaalik donc on voit très
bien qu'il ya un côté qui a plus de
l'epide autriche que l'autre il ya un
côté qui est vraiment fait pour attaquer
en fait là pour attaquer le lot il ya un
autre côté qui est plutôt là pour donner
de la pousser à l'eau avec les lipides
autriche
donc cette asymétrie elle ressemble à la
symétrie du développement qu'on voit
chez les tétrapodes moderne
donc vous avez un humérus au début après
l'humérus vous avez le développement du
radius et de lille n'a donc des deux
zigues au pod des 2 go pod pardon et
après vous n'avez qu'un seul de ces deux
os qui va se diviser en deux et ensuite
vous avez un seul de ces deux os qui va
se diviser en deux et ainsi de suite
donné naissance à tous vos atouts vont
métacarpe ou evo carpe ou à tous vos
métatarse et vautard si vous êtes sur le
pied ea eo doit évidemment donc et aux
phalanges
donc c'est cette asymétrie du
développement en fait avec un côté qui
va se diviser mais pas l'autre
c'est ce qu'on retrouve o'shea aussi
chez les tétrapodes et c'est ce qui
donne au tétrapodes la forme de leurs
mains et ça c'est ça c'est très
intéressant du coup de voir ça chez elle
piste host et j'ai ça montre que son
développement est et le développement de
ses membres était le même que celui d'un
tétrapodes est donc lâché tiktaalik vous
avez ça aussi donc j'ai choisi pareil
j'ai choisi l piste au stage est plutôt
petit à annick parce que lepisto steger
beaucoup plus complète tiktaalik le
fossile s'arrête là donc vous avez la
tête vous avez le léman les membres
antérieurs ne n'avais pas l'arrière donc
vous n'avez pas en fait chez tiktaalik
vous n'avez accès presque à la partie
qui est la plus tétrapodes de la
morphologie mais vous n'avez pas
tellement accès à la point à la partie
très poissonneuses
voilà de sa morphologie dont je trouve
que c'est plus intéressant de voir une
piste ho steger en entier parce que lui
il a vraiment l'aspect d'un poisson et
c'est vraiment quand on s'intéresse au
détail du crâne qu'on voit que son crâne
c'est la forme de celui d'un amphibien
que la position des yeux c'est comme
chez les amphibiens que le les encoches
aux tic c'est comme chez les amphibiens
que les épaules détaché du crâne
c'est les amphibiens donc voilà ça ça se
voit beaucoup mieux chez une piste ho
steger que chez tiktaalik mais bon je
reconnais quand même que tu italie
qu'existe un ne vous en faites pas je
suis au courant qu'il est là donc voilà
tout ça ça indique que l pisto steger et
un poisson sarko parisien à tête et un
bras de tétrapodes et ça c'est quand
même c'est quand même super classe ce
qui nous amène du coup aux premiers
tétrapodes les premiers tétrapodes que
son iq tio stega et à caen tous tes gars
donc là on peut pas les éviter cela je
veux dire c'est des grands classiques
donc on va quand même en parler donc ici
au séga et à caen toaster gars qui ont
la plupart des traits qu'on peut
associer aux amphibiens donc le crâne
très arrondi la surface complètement
complètement perforé vous voyez par
plein de petits trous sensitif
un peu comme les crocodiles donc ça
indique aussi un mode de vie sain
indique quand même qu'ils passaient
beaucoup de leur vie immergé puisqu'ils
ont tous ses petits-enfants tous ces
petits trous qui chez les crocodiles
sont des organes qui permettent de
capter la pression de l'eau donc on
imagine que c'était à peu près pareil
chez eux les yeux qui sont plutôt sommet
du crâne dons qui permettent de voir au
dessus de l'eau vous voyez que sur la
queue il y a encore des epide autriche
tchéquie host et gaillac en toast et
gasquet indique qu'ils pouvaient encore
se déplacer efficacement dans l'autre
est très efficacement dans l'eau les
articulations notamment du coude et du
coude et de et du genou sont pas très
mobile ni chez l'un et chez l'autre ce
qui encore une fois indiquent qu'ils
n'étaient pas super à l'aise sur le sol
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut
relativiser aussi cette idée de sortie
des eaux un petit os tega quant au
stella était pas tout à fait terrestre
tout n'était pas tout à fait terrestre
alors qu'on les considère comme étant
les parmi les premiers tétrapodes
d'ailleurs comme étant les premiers
tétrapodes avec l piste host et gilles
ça change un peu en fait la différence
entre tétrapodes et pas tétrapodes en
fait on l'avait arbitrairement placé sur
l'origine des doigts mais sachant que en
2019 on a décrit l pisto steger et que
lepisto steger à 2 pts 6
qu'on suppose être des doigts ici du
coup ça voudrait dire quelles pistes au
cgn est un tétrapodes maintenant il est
plus considéré comme un poisson sarcopte
est rien or son corps est quand même
vachement celui d'un sarko
d'appréhension sarkozien donc là au
moins avec kitty est égal à canto cet
égard on est quand même face à des
animaux qui ont globalement plutôt un
squelette d'amphibiens à part pour les
lépi d'autriche de la queue on est quand
même plutôt sur un squelette
d'amphibiens le crâne est typiquement
celui d'un amphibien vous voyez les olé
les encoches aux tic qui sont là on a un
qu'on dit l'occiput al donc un poids d'à
tâche de la tête avec le reste du corps
qui indiquent qu'il y avait une
articulation entre le coût et la tête ce
qui n'est pas le cas chez les poissons
enfin vous avez évidemment la tête qui
est accroché au cou chez les poissons
enfin aux vertèbres mais il n'ya pas
d'articulation qui permettent de bouger
la tête là vous avez un conte deal et
vous avez une vertèbre qui s'appelle
l'atlas qui porte la tête un peu comme
atlas porter le monde
là vous avez une vertèbre qui s'appelle
l'atlas qui porte la tête en petites
références mythologiques et qui permet
l'articulation de la tête et notamment
des mouvements de base en haut c'est au
moins au moins ses mouvements après il y
aura l'axis qui évoluera plus tard chez
les amis note qui permettra les
mouvements de gauche à droite mais pour
l'instant il ya que l'atlas chez xo cet
égard quand tous tes gars et celle et
chez les amphibiens en général donc
amphibiens moderne inclut les amphibiens
modernes ils ont aussi cette forme
arrondie du crâne d'ailleurs ils ont
aussi les orbites plutôt dirigés vers le
haut et il ya pas mal de d'amphibiens
modernes comme les comme les boules frog
par exemple donc les les gros crapaud
buffle qui ont une surface du crâne
ornementé de cette façon donc c'est pas
les amphibiens encore une fois même si
vous du point de vue phylogénétique
c'est pas un groupe qui est qui et
phylogénétiquement juste c'est un groupe
qui morphologiquement anatomiquement
reste quand même assez cohérent on a
aussi des innovations qui permettent de
renforcer la colonne vertébrale et
notamment
présence de ce qu'on appelle les igg
apophis donc les igg apophis et les
articulations vous voyez ici
qui paiera qui permettent aux vertèbres
de s'articuler les unes aux autres dont
vous avez la peau fils postérieur qui
s'articule à la peau fils antérieures de
la vertèbre précédente et ainsi de suite
et ça fait comme un pont suspendu en
fait donc ça permet de soutenir le corps
les vertèbres s'appuient les unes sur
les autres et vous avez évidemment le
fait que les vertèbres s'appuient les
unes sur les autres n'auraient aucun
intérêt si vous ne pouvez pas si tout ça
ne reposait pas sur des fondations
solides et ses fondations solides c'est
le bassin qui est maintenant attaché à
la colonne vertébrale par une vertèbre
qu'on appelle la vertèbre sacré donc le
bassin est attaché par une vertèbre ici
à la colonne vertébrale donc il ya une
donc il y à ce qu'on appelle une
vertèbre sacré et on va voir ce nombre
augmenter au fur et à mesure que les que
les tétrapodes vont s'adapter au milieu
terrestre les tétrapodes ont
généralement cinq doigts du moins c'est
la formule primitive chez les tétrapodes
mais xxi au séga et à quant aux dégâts
sont uniques
de ce point de vue dans le sens que ils
ont entre sept et huit doigts en
fonction de si on regarde le bras avant
le bras enfin le en fonction de si on
regarde le bras ou la jambe et en
fonction des deux espèces donc c'est un
petit peu c'est étonnant de voir ça chez
eux ont ce qu'on voit ici ce sont les
trois premiers doit en fait et on
s'imagine que ces trois premiers doigts
sont qu'ils sont tout petits vont être
ceux qui vont disparaître ou fusionner
ensemble pour donner le premier doigt ou
disparaître pour laisser les autres
doigts en fonction du nombre de doigts
de base voilà donc c'est plutôt marrant
et ça ne se trouve que celle ci est égal
quant aux dégâts donc au dévonien vous
aviez huit doigts dont trois très réduit
et
c'est seulement au carbonifère en fait
chez des espèces comme tu l'erp et ont
par exemple que le nombre de doigts va
tomber à 5
et ça va être le nombre de doigts
primitif
après pour les l'évolution des
tétrapodes après ça donc après il va y
avoir surtout des réductions du nombre
de doigts rarement des augmentations ça
va arriver dès fois chez les
ichthyosaures par exemple mais
généralement on va plus tôt avoir des
réductions du nombre de doigts et donc
l'afrique était plutôt pauvre en ski et
en termes de d'amphibiens du dévonien
jusqu'à ce qu'on découvre deux animaux
toulouse uc où nous en tient dans le
devon ya supérieur d'afrique du sud donc
avant la découverte de toulouse uc une
zone 6 heures on pensait que les
amphibiens fait que les tétrapodes ne
pouvait avoir évolué que dans un climat
tropical
ce qui semble assez raisonnable je veux
dire c'est quand même là qu'il ya le
plus de diversité donc on fait le pari
raisonnable que là où il ya le plus de
diversité il ya plus de chances que des
innovations et lieux et à l'époque comme
l'afrique au dévonien était plutôt
situés en plein sur le pôle sud
on s'imaginait pas que c'était par là
que ça s'était passé les continents
globalement étaient tous beaucoup plus
au sud
qu'ils ne le sont aujourd'hui donc
l'afrique était positionné en place sur
le pôle sud
et vous aviez le l'europe et l'amérique
du nord et notamment le justement ces
régions qui ont livré des beaucoup de
restes d'amphibiens du dévonien comme le
groenland où on a trouvé tiktaalik et
puis vous avez la scandinavie où on a
trouvé les cinq ans toaster gatineau
stega sas était situé au niveau des
tropiques et c'est là qu'on trouvait le
plus de diversité d'amphibiens du
dévonien donc on se disait qu'il y avait
absolument aucune chance que les
amphibiens soit apparue ailleurs qu'au
niveau de ces régions tropicales
oui mais il ya quelques années de cela
il ya à peine deux trois ans on a
découvert tout aux us et au monde entier
a qui sont des amphibiens qui datent du
dévonien alors on en a pas grand chose
pour l'instant donc il n'y a pas de non
plus de quoi crier à la révolution
mais ce qu'on a c'est en fait des eaux
de la ceinture scapulaire donc un os qu
on appelle le clae itron et cette hausse
de la ceinture scapulaire et bien il est
séparé du crâne ce qui indique bel et
bien que on est face à un animal dont
les épaules était détaché de la tête
donc un animal qui raisonnablement on
peut le supposer avait d une encoche aux
tic et avait un crâne vraiment très
similaire à celui des lepisto steger
donc déjà rien que le fait d'avoir
trouvé ses clés itron de toulouse uc
double anciens indique que ces animaux
avait une ceinture scapulaire détaché du
crâne dont qu'ils avaient un coup
donc il ressemblait énormément au moins
à l piste steger sinon même à 1 quant
aux dégâts et le kiosque dégâts
maintenant on pense que tout aux yeux
c'était plus proche de l pisto steger
parce qu'en fait son clé itron a une
surface qui est recouvert de petites
perforations et c'est qu'on retrouve
chez les sarko pirisiens plus bazot
alors que vous me sentis à lui il serait
un peu plus proche de dicter aux dégâts
est d'accord tous tes gars et ça s'est
basée sur le fait que la sur son os
maxillaire ici donc le petit haut ce que
vous voyez représenter la en verre sur
son ans maxillaire vous avez ici
l'oeil lors bit était situé à cet
endroit là or chez les alpilles chez
elle piste et j'ai par exemple ou chez
tiktaalik l'oeil est sur l'os lacrymal
et pas sur l'os maxillaire qui se trouve
là
l'os maxillaire ne participe pas alors
bits chez les épices toaster g chez les
pistes aux tgv tiktaalik alors que chez
iqt ist gaillac en tous cas ici vous
avez l'os maxillaire et vous voyez que
il participe alors bits donc ça ça
indiquera comme aux anciens est plutôt
proche de daccan toaster gars et dicter
aux dégâts et ça c'est intéressant parce
que ça vous indique que non seulement on
trouve des tétrapodes du dévonien sur un
continent qui était normalement
complètement recours
de glace donc ça veut dire que l'essai
amphibiens il était quand même
il était quand même capable de vivre
dans des lieux d'un des très hautes
latitudes dans des milieux très froid
mais ça vous montre qu'en plus il était
capable d'être diversifiée parce qu'on a
quand même deux de morpho morphologie
qui sont très différentes si on part du
principe que tout soucieuse ressemblait
plus à une piste ho steger c'était
beaucoup plus un poisson donc ce que
c'est ce qui est représentée là alors
que si vous regardez où nous antilles à
lui il était un peu plus terrestre donc
on avait une diversité de ces animaux et
ça ça ça remet pas mal de choses en
question notamment par rapport à l'idée
que ce que l'évolution des tétrapodes ne
peut avoir été qu'un événement de
l'hémisphère nord donc ça c'est très
intéressant et ça c'est un des avantages
aussi de prendre en compte les choses
des fois qu'ils ne sont pas présentés
justement dans l'est dans l'est dans les
bouquins de cours qui sont écrits
strictement dans l'hémisphère nord
justement parce qu'ils ont tendance un
peu à négliger ce genre de données qui
bat qui sont encore marginales je veux
dire il ya quand même pas non plus tant
de fossiles que ça comme vous pouvez le
voir on a une jolie mâchoire on a un
bout de crâne on a un bout de deux
ceinture scapulaire mai mais quand même
c'est le simple fait que ces fausses il
existe là où ils existent indique quand
même qu'il ya peut-être une des gros
seins des gros paradigme sur l'origine
des tétrapodes qui pourrait être faux et
c'est pas c'est pas négligeable
voilà c'est pas négligeable pardon c'est
non négligeable
voilà voilà à peu près donc là on les a
retrouvés en afrique du sud donc
l'afrique du sud n'était pas totalement
non plus sur le pôle mais en même temps
cette carte n'est pas forcément la carte
de l'afrique au dévonien au dévonien
supérieur donc bon il ya une marge
d'erreur sur la représentation mais ça
vous indique quand même que quand je
vous dis que l'afrique était en plein
sur le pôle je déconne pas quoi
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui donc
la prochaine fois nous parlerons des
premiers tétrapodes donc les amphibiens
notamment et nous parlerons aussi de
l'origine des amiotte à très bientôt